unser nächster Gast Cosma Shiva Hagen in
der Internet Movie Database als
Schauspielerin schon seit 15 Jahren im
Geschäft und noch keine 30 das ist schon
eine legendäre Leistung sie ist die
Tochter von Nina Hagen Sängerin auf die
wart mal schon eine Weile hier bei
klicksum und Eva Maria Hagen
Schauspielerin also eine richtige
Dynastie googelt das mal sehr spannend
und ich denke auch unser Interview wird
sehr spannend und noch mal spannend wird
dann die Beantwortung eurer nutzerfragen
wenn ihr euch was einfallen lassen hier
im Video ist ein Link wo er draufklicken
könnt oder unten ins Kommentarfeld gegen
Unternehmen taucht dann auch einen Link
auf und liest unter dem Video den
Infotext klickt auf die Links und dann
kann eigentlich nichts mehr schief gehen
ich drücke die Daumen